maksim chmerkovskiy slams former Dancing  with the Stars partner hope solo no love  lost here one more dancing with the  stars pro was as unfiltered as ever on  the podcast allegedly not holding back  any feelings about a season 13 partner  he said quote she's just a tea person  you can have a life growing up but if  you're a bad person there's no excuse  for that Feud stems from allegations  hope made in her 2012 memoir in which  she claims Maxim quote manhandled her  and quote slapped her across the face  during rehearsals Maxim has denied the  allegations EG has reached out to hopes  rep for comment max parted ways with a  hit ABC show after winning season 18 et  has reached out to hopes wrap for  comment but hope seemingly fired back  and Maxim on Twitter simply posting in  this shot of the judges holding up the  lowest score possible ones across the  board yay